Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. Will the Trump FBI raid
get more Republicans voting in November?
That's the question this viewer asks.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Angie in Wisconsin
just finished voting in our primary and I
realized after last night's raid on Mar a Lago,
I wonder if this is going to bring out a lot more
Republicans than normal, which is not good for
Wisconsin, because we have our governor's race and
Senate race where I'd like to see Ron Johnson go.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is a completely reasonable
question. And during our live stream yesterday
of the FBI raid of Donald Trump's Mar a Lago
house and toilet and safe and everything. One of
the things that I was saying was, is it possible
that Republicans will be so in the maggots mostly
will be will they be so infuriated by the raid
that now all of a sudden they will be
revitalized and inspired to vote in November?
It's absolutely possible. At the same time, would
that be a reason for a law enforcement agency not
to do what the evidence says they have to do? Of
course not. You have to do what the evidence says.
And if at this point, there's probable cause to
say, we believe that there is evidence of a crime
at Mar a Lago, and it could be in Trump's personal
quarters, it could be in a safe. Then you have to
follow that and then deal with the repercussions
as they come. I don't want the FBI. You know,
one of the problems with the FBI in the past that
we've talked about is they take actions that seem
to go above and beyond, like, for example, James
Comey's second press conference about Hillary
Clinton, which arguably lost her the election in
2016. Was that a necessary press conference? No,
they did an investigation. There was already
a press conference. Why do a second one
here? I don't want the FBI saying,
well, maybe because it'll hurt
to know if there's probable cause and you have
the evidence and a judge signs off on it and
you've got all the I's dotted and T's crossed,
then you have to do what the evidence says,
and we will deal with the political repercussions.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We're going to talk about the new funding for
the IRS and the reconciliation bill and what
that might lead to. We will talk about a town
dissolving its police department after a police
officer sent a racist text. And we will talk
about Ron DeSantis trying to suspend a prosecutor
and how the prosecutor is reacting. All of those
stories are on today's bonus show. Sign up at
join pacman dot com. Become a member. That's
our primary funding source for this program
and you will get instant access to the bonus show.
We will see you on the bonus show in mere moments.